[Music]
ever
[Applause]
I'll be the judge of that is that really
the best video ever did a singer in a
movie mean to hawk a loogie
will Harry Styles get an acquittal for
hitting Chris Pine with spittle
a video of singer Harry Styles appearing
to clobber actor Chris Pine with slobber
went viral last night during the
premiere of their new film we don't
really give it no that's not the name of
it
it's called don't worry darling it's the
hottest movie news since Morgan Freeman
wiped a booger on Jessica Tandy
that didn't happen it's now breaking the
internet much like when America faked
the moon landing
hi kid there was no internet back then
[Laughter]
stupid
you guys here's the tape
[Music]
rumors of onset tension between the film
star Florence Pew or Pooh who cares and
director Olivia Wilde have been
circulating much like me at a high
school prom
last year
Harry Styles is Florence's co-star but
Olivia's real-life boyfriend not trying
to make me jealous right Olivia
I'm watching you last night Harry's
other co-star Chris Pine spoke highly of
Florence which might have ticked off
Harry so did Harry Styles pull a Will
Smith but with saliva instead of a slap
roll it again Doris
all right let's watch it again
hahaha
so what do you think did he really spit
or not now if he did then what next
should they settle this with us this
spat with a televised oil wrestling
match I'd watch that at any rate next
time Harry if you're upset try to act
like an adult be a man next time swallow
[Laughter]
what
rather than spit on
your saliva
you guys are so disgusting Mercedes uh
what do you think of this I hear they're
gonna go get checked for monkey pox
we'll give you an update on the results
yeah I love it when a joke about monkey
pox gets Applause
have you been following this Saga I have
I just watched the Cliff of the
hundredth time I feel like Harry should
have spit on whoever picked out his
outfit yeah and that's coming from you
yeah I mean seriously
Jimmy
I got a theory Harry didn't start
dressing like this until you got hired
by Fox news thank you
thank you well I do look like the lead
singer of a boy band called wrong
direction but
um
I just think it's so stupid but you know
who's happy the producers are happy
because that's the only way this film is
going to get traction it's apparently a
terrible movie it's it's garbage okay
nobody goes to the movie theater anymore
unless it's a Marvel hero or Tom Cruise
you either need a cape or a
Scientologist or nobody's showing up so
this is a win for the producers
there's some theaters I still freak with
Tom
Reuben's I happen to be staying at a
friend's house and I don't have my own
room
I'll go to the old local theater yeah
I'm back it's in the back and watch some
erotic Thriller
the ones with the stickiest floor yes
Greg Tom Tom look I had to watch this
thing several times today and then you
made me watch it again and again and I
wasn't seeing anything I was looking I
was like what is this a story I don't
see spit I don't know if it's at the
beginning or at the end I didn't see any
spit it couldn't have happened and then
I looked on uh Twitter and they have a
fact Checker saying no Harry Styles did
not spit on Chris Pine and I said I
think he spit on him
they don't they don't fact check it
unless it's true
fact Checkers excuse me I almost burped
there back Checkers are never right
Dagan they're never right they're
they're absolutely never right this is
the lead story on The Hollywood Reporter
and variety that's how big the denial
that he spit on it right I think it was
maybe a little perspiration off his brow
but I'm more fascinated with Chris Pine
he appears to be wearing a wig from the
Brad Pitt collection yeah
coming off an audition for the new
improved Falcon Crest and he's also
chewing gum at this Venice Film Festival
how bad does your halitosis have to be
that you're gnawing on some juicy fruit
we're near in Venice it could be
nicotine nicotine gun oh you got to do
the nicotine under the lip that gets you
going oh you should try that you should
try the suppository
talk about smoking a butt
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else